eu ministers meet on tuesday at the
education youth culture and sport
council the meeting will start with a
cultural session where the council is
due to adopt conclusions on the european
audio visual policy in the digital era
their aim is to facilitate the supply of
high quality audio visual content meet
audience demands anywhere in the eu and
ensure equal conditions for all audio
visual media service providers
the adoption of the conclusions comes at
a strategic moment since the creation of
a digital single market is among the top
priorities of the new commission
the council will also establish a work
plan for culture setting out the
priorities for european corporation in
cultural policy making for the next four
years
furthermore conclusions will be adopted
on participatory governance of cultural
heritage
the idea that member states promote a
more active involvement of members of
society and the private sector in this
project
a debate will also take place on the
contribution of cultural and creative
sectors towards the europe 2020
objectives
ministers will discuss how those sectors
can help create a smart sustainable and
inclusive growth and stimulate social
and economic innovation
in the afternoon eu ministers for sport
will address the issue of innovation in
the sector and its positive effects on
the economy as a whole
you